wir stehen jetzt also vor dem zweiten
lockdown und viele menschen fragen sich
jetzt was bitte also was genau
verspricht uns dass es nicht dahingehend
direkt danach die dritte vierte
vielleicht sogar fünfte welle gibt und
wir immer wieder jetzt in diesen
teufelskreis kommen das ist eine absolut
berechtigte frage und die muss uns
natürlich beschäftigen und es muss ganz
klar sein dass das eigentlich nicht sinn
und zweck dieses locker und sein kann
dass wir vier wochen später den nächsten
gehen müssen
wir haben jetzt vier wochen zeit wenn
das alltagsgeschehen runter gefahren
wird sehr schnell uns zu überlegen wie
wir danach weitermachen und es kann
nicht so weitergehen wie es jetzt vor
diesem lockdown gegangen ist weil wir
haben ja letztendlich die kontrolle
verloren
wir müssen sehr viel intensiver wieder
dafür sorgen dass die regeln eingehalten
werden also abstand hygiene und die
alltags masken getragen werden wir
müssen dafür sorgen dass sehr gut
gelüftet wird in den innenräumen
beziehungsweise durch technische
möglichkeiten die erosion konzentration
in den räumen deutlich geringer wird und
das muss sehr sehr konsequent und noch
konsequenter eingehalten werden als
bisher
und dann haben wir eine chance dann so
was wie wir jetzt in den nächsten vier
wochen erleben werden nicht nochmal
machen zu müssen
wir sind verhalten eher denken sie denn
aber dass dieser london ist kollegen von
ihnen unter anderen der virologe
professor hendrik speck hatte sich ja
vor dem großen lockdown gipfel der
regierung ausgesprochen dass das nicht
der richtige weg ist man solle andere
pläne haben wo die risikogruppen besser
geschützt werden was denken sie über die
vorschläge
oder ist das jetzt der richtige weg den
die regierung geht wer die vorschläge
sind ja insgesamt wichtig die einzige
wobei uns großartig unterscheiden ist
der weg wie wir dorthin kommen wieder
die kontrolle zu erhalten und wir können
meiner meinung nach die risikogruppen
und das sind ja nicht nur alte menschen
in pflegeheimen risikogruppe ist auch
jemand der ein herz problem hat jemand
der übergewichtig ist und bluthochdruck
hat wir müssen also im prinzip fast die
hälfte der bevölkerung wenn man das
strengen genau nehmen sehr gut schützen
der beste schutz vor einer meinung nach
ist wenn wir die infektionszahlen wieder
soweit unterdrücken das sie
kontrollieren können und dann brauchen
wir natürlich konzepte und da haben die
kollegen recht dass wir perspektiven
schaffen wie wir das stabil niedrig
halten
aber wir haben meiner meinung nach keine
alternative zu dem jetzigen lockdown um
wieder kontrollierbare situation zu
haben um unsere älter bevölkerung unsere
risiko bevölkerung insgesamt besser
schützen zu können
der lockt dann wird dann den ganzen
monat gelten also vier wochen aber nach
14 tagen möchte die regierung das erste
mal schauen wie sich die zahlen
entwickeln
momentan haben wir bereits über 18.000
neuinfektionen am tag die frage ist
welche zahlen sind in zwei wochen dann
ausschlaggebend dafür um zu sehen ob
dieser lockt dort tatsächlich ein erfolg
ist ja wir werden natürlich hoffen dass
die tägliche neuinfektionsrate deutlich
nach unten geht
wir werden sehen ob die positive rate
also die anteile der positiv getesteten
personen bei unserem gesamten ob die
deutlich sinkt die produktionszahl ist
sicherlich wichtig man darf aber nicht
vergessen auch wenn man montag der lok
tor startet ist damit zu rechnen dass
wir trotzdem erstmal ein paar tage
weiterhin steigende zahlen sehen werden
bis zu mindestens einer woche danach wir
müssen damit rechnen dass auch die
intensivbetten belegung weiter zunimmt
durch patienten weil das alles nach
laufende prozesse sind also es erst mal
wichtig die zahlen nicht gleich zu
bewerten nach drei tagen und zu sagen
das hat er alles nicht funktioniert das
ist alles überflüssig nicht umsonst
nimmt sich die regierung 14 tage zeit um
die situation zu bewerten und die werden
auch diverse parameter gucken und da
gehören insgesamt auch die von mir
genannten zahlen dazu inklusive
natürlich auch bewegung der
intensivbetten jetzt ist komisch ich
kein problem nur hier in deutschland
sondern eine weltweite pandemie gibt es
länder die das in ihren augen von anfang
an besser gehandhabt haben und wenn ja
was haben sie anders gemacht also
insgesamt bin ich der meinung dass wir
in deutschland eigentlich über die ganze
zeit sehr gut aufgestellt waren wir
haben es geschafft in einer ersten phase
der pandemie das ganze relativ gut in
den griff zu bekommen wir haben über die
sommermonate ein sehr sehr entspanntes
infektionsgeschehen in deutschland
beobachten können und im vergleich zu
unserer ausländischen nachbarn haben wir
auch in der zweiten welle die wir jetzt
durchaus auch nennen dürfen
sehr sehr viel besser dagestanden als
andere insofern halte ich unseren weg
weil ich für sehr gut man kann im
nachhinein immer sagen das ein oder
andere hätte man besser machen können da
hat man nicht zu machen können da hat
man nicht so restriktiv sein müssen aber
im vergleich zu unseren nachbarn
geht es uns immer noch sehr gut
jetzt die große hoffnung ist natürlich
ein impfstoff experten sagen jetzt es
könnte aber bis 2022 dauern bis so viel
davon da ist dass wir flächendeckend
genug geimpft sind um zu sagen man hat
kohona jetzt überstanden
teilen sie diese befürchtungen also ich
denke wir haben ja jeder impfstoffe in
der entwicklung in der letzten phase der
klinischen zulassung die auch anderen
techniken basieren die wir ja noch gar
nicht in der form beim menschen bisher
gehabt haben ich denke an den bond
impfstoff der ja auch diesem sogenannten
mrsa also messenger rna prinzip beruht
dort ist es ja deutlich schneller
möglich eine große anzahl von impfdosen
herzustellen biontech hat sich ja auch
gut vorbereitet was die produktion
angeht
ich gehe davon aus dass wir die
zulassung erfolgt wird natürlich nicht
sofort flächendeckend impfen können das
ist auf jeden fall eine logistische
herausforderung
ich bin aber optimist dass wir das in 20
21 noch zumindest für die risikogruppen
auf jeden fall hinbekommen werden mehr
nachrichten und breaking news nur bei
bate schau dich hier das nächste video
an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren